[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct sur avis de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir comment aider davantage
les ukrainiens sur le plan militaire
c'est l'une des discussions majeur des
vingt-sept réunis en grande pompe à
versailles ce soir l'union européenne
livre des armes l'allemagne opère un
tournant stratégique et l'otan se
réveille mais tout cela est il suffisant
les images de l'hôpital pour enfants
bombardé à marioupol ont horrifié le
monde alors le retour de la guerre en
europe va t-il enfin faire naître une
europe puissance une europe de la
défense on en débat avec nos invités
dans un instant sur ce plateau notre
grand témoin ce soir est un grand
spécialiste de la russie et du monde
orthodoxe historiens théologiens auteur
d'un livre de référence l'apocalypse
russe dieu au pays de dostoïevski il
nous dira ce qui se passe selon lui dans
la tête de vladimir poutine jean
françois colossimo est avec nous ce soir
enfin ce sera la page présidentielle
avec votre nouveau rendez vous le scan
chaque soir trois chroniqueurs qui passe
au crible en fait campagne et puis bien
sûr l'oeil de blacko le carnet de
campagne de stéphane blakowski à 31
jours après jours du premier tour
seulement voilà pour le menu c'est parti
m
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'être au rendez
vous bonsoir jean françois colosimo
vous accueillir historiens théologiens
éditeurs grand connaisseur du monde
russes et du monde orthodoxe on a besoin
de votre lecture ce soir à la fois
culturelles spirituelles historique
évidemment pour comprendre ce qui se
joue dans cette guerre d'une violence
inouïe on l'a vu encore aujourd'hui à à
marioupol on vous posera cette question
un peu provocatrice de savoir ce qui se
passe dans la tête de vladimir poutine
s'il est plus isolé que jamais comme
certains observateurs du kremlin peuvent
peuvent le dire aujourd'hui mais on va
commencer avec l'actualité qui se joue
ce soir à versailles regardez ces images
dans la cour pavée devant le château de
versailles et sa garde républicaine le
chef de l'état qui accueille les 27
dirigeants de l'union qui sont tous au
pied du mur si l'on peut dire ce soir
l'agenda est évidemment bouleversé par
la guerre en ukraine emmanuel macron et
ses homologues qui vont parler autonomie
stratégique investissements dans la
défense qui nous intéresse ce soir mais
aussi adhésion de l'ukraine on en parle
avec vous nathalie l'oiseau bonsoir
bonsoir merci d'être là députée
européenne du groupe renew renaissance
le groupe macro nist ancien ministre
chargé des affaires européennes bonsoir
ronan le gleut bienvenue vous êtes
sénateur les républicains des français
de l'étranger c'est bien ça et bonsoir
marica parta bienvenue spécialiste de
l'allemagne et chercheuse à l'ifri je
vous donne la parole dans un instant va
d'abord rejoindre stéphanie des pierres
qui a suivi pour lcp ce début de sommet
à versailles bonsoir stéphanie donc les
27 ont beaucoup de pain sur la planche
si l'on peut dire même si c'est un
sommet informel quels sont les grands
dossiers chauds sur la table
le plus gros dossier c'est l'énergie en
europe 40% du gaz vient de russie s'est
même 55 % pour l'allemagne
l'enjeu de ce sommet est donc de trouver
comment et à quel rythme réduire cette
dépendance énergétique
d'autres secteurs comme les semi
conducteurs et les en grèce seront aussi
à l'ordre du jour et puis les 27
discuteront de comment amortir les
conséquences économiques de la crise
ukrainienne la france pousse pour un
nouveau plan de relance et
d'investissement à l'image de ce qui
s'était fait pour le coc vide mais elle
est encore un peu seule union européenne
en tout cas est ébranlée par cette
guerre en ukraine c'est le constat qu'a
fait emmanuel macron en accueillant tout
à l'heure les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement ici à versailles
l'europe doit changer elle a changé sous
le coup de la pandémie elle va changer
encore plus vite et plus fort sous le
coup de la guerre
parce que la guerre en ukraine est un
bouleversement profond de nos équilibres
des croyances qui avait gagné notre
continent et donc elle doit nous
conduire à être lucide ambitieux et
prendre les décisions qui sont à la
hauteur alors ce soir en plateau
stéphanie on va s'arrêter sur le volet
défense on a beaucoup entendu dire que
depuis cette invasion russe c'était leur
puissance ou l'europe de la défense qui
était relancé on va vous poser la
question bien sûr mais que peuvent
décider précisément les vingt-sept sur
ce volet stratégique sur ce volet
défense alors que l'on sait bien sûr que
c'est la compétence nationale des états
souverains par excellence
oui on la guerre en ukraine a servi à
d'électrochoc l'europe s'est rendu
compte qu'elle ne faisait pas le poids
militairement face à une russie est
menaçante alors faut-il resserrer les
liens entre l'union européenne et l'otan
faut-il bâtir les fondations les
fondations pardon d'une véritable armée
européenne faut-il créer enfin une
europe de la défense ce sont toutes ces
questions qui sont débattues aujourd'hui
et demain ici à versailles a minima les
vingt-sept devraient s'engager à
investir plus dans les dépenses
militaires pays par pays déjà certains
ont fait volte-face l'allemagne par
exemple qui réduisait ses effectifs
depuis 30 ans a décidé d'augmenter très
fortement à ses dépenses militaires et
puis vous le savez fin février c'était
un tournant historique c'était inédit
l'union européenne a débloqué 500
millions d'euros pour financer l'achat
et la livraison d'armes d'équipements
militaires de missiles notamment pour
aider l'ukraine
merci infiniment stéphane et nathalie
loiseau vous faites partie de celles qui
est quelques jours après l'invasion
avait écrit ça y est leur puissance est
née après cette invasion et après bien
sûr les premières sanctions les grandes
décisions européennes il a fallu pour
vous cette guerre pour qu'on fasse
tomber des réticences et même des tabous
de notre histoire européenne exactement
depuis longtemps emmanuel macron
plaidait pour une défense européenne
pour ne serait-ce qu'une politique
étrangère
claire nette et rapide en cas de crise
et depuis longtemps beaucoup de d'état
membres pensaient que ça c'était un luxe
pour un jour peut-être que c'était une
vision idéologique
fédéraliste le gros mot et qu'il ne
fallait surtout pas s'en approcher
à mon modeste niveau je plaidais pour la
défense européenne en disant on répare
son 3 quand il fait beau on n'attend pas
qu'il pleuve et une crise puisque on dit
toujours que l'europe avance dans les
crises une crise en matière de défense
ça s'appelle une guerre et c'est quand
même très tardif il a fallu une guerre
mais c'est vrai que depuis le 24 février
quelques jours on a fait plus que vous
diriez quoi rance trente dernières
années alors on avait commencé à faire
quelques progrès depuis quelques années
des outils été mise en place mais il
fallait pousser en permanence
expliqué que le monde était de plus en
plus dangereux que notre projet de pays
européens commençaient à regard à
ressembler à un troupeau d'herbivores
dans un monde de carnivores et qu'il
fallait s'adapter
depuis quelques jours en réalité et ça a
été dit de l'argent européen est destiné
à livrer des armes en ukraine elles sont
omis siens de chars vrai silence y
arriverez jamais ce qu'on met livre
manière un peu globale selon lui même de
manille la france je deviens que la
france est secret défense mais l'union
européenne ne le doit qu'à nous mêmes on
a quelques et l'union européenne ne le
dit pas non plus pour de très bonnes
raisons
que la question avec efficacité parce
que c'est très important un tournant
d'avancer de se dire que voilà on a peur
tout le monde a peur on sent bien que ce
conflit pourrait s'étendre on ne sait
pas comment ça va se terminer ronan le
gleut ont dit on vous c'est la fin d'un
tabou on livre des armes létales on
finance tout ça sur un budget repères
mais quand même je voulais montrer ces
images elles sont difficiles parce que
on parle de cette europe de la défense
et en même temps il ya des enfants qui
meurent sous les bombes et encore
aujourd'hui et c'est vraiment atroce
hôpital pour enfants bombardé à marie
gopaul hier trois civils tués une
fillette des dizaines de blessés a garé
dans des décombres vraiment ces images
sont insupportables
c'est un pays complètement complètement
en ruines au fond on se dit que ces
sanctions s'est passé ça marche pas même
si l'europe se construit plus vite sur
ces questions stratégiques ces images
sont insoutenables
et il est vrai de dire que l'ukraine
n'est pas membre ni de l'otan ni de
l'union européenne et cette distinction
est absolument fondamental dans la
structure de la défense en europe parce
que ce qui garantit la sécurité des pays
d'europe centrale et orientale
c'est à la fois l'adhésion dans l'union
européenne à travers l'article 42 tirs
et 7 du traité de l'union européenne et
la constitution lente progressive d'un
des buts de défense européenne mais nous
n'y sommes pas la véritable garantie de
sécurité encore aujourd'hui malgré
malgré les avancées qui ont pu être
effectivement rapide c'est l'otan c'est
de l'article 5 du traité de l'atlantique
nord et nos partenaires les pays baltes
la pologne la roumanie le disent tous il
suffit de se rendre à varsovie ou dans
les capitales ce qui est pour eux la
garantie de sécurité ce n'est pas
l'union européen sans les américains ce
sujet de la présence militaire et la
présence de soldats sur leur propre sol
de soldats américains alors j'aurai
absolument américain aujourd'hui en
roumanie les soldats de la présence
avancée de l'otan qui viennent d'arriver
ce sont des soldats français mais c'est
vrai sous drapeaux de l'otan c'est
normal la défense européenne est encore
embryonnaire et les mêmes pays pays
baltes pologne roumanie bulgarie que
site renan le gleut aujourd'hui on en
vit à la fois de plus d'autant mais
aussi plus d'union européenne alors on
va les souvenirs d'épisodes de l'iphone
ils savent très bien que avec un
président différent du président biden
les choses pourraient être beaucoup plus
fragile oui on va essayer de voir ce que
ça voudrait dire un peu plus de défense
européenne tout en restant dans l'otan
certains candidats d'ailleurs à
l'élection présidentielle voudrait
carrément quitté l'otan ou son
commandement intégré mais si on se pose
ces questions là c'est quand même pour
les aider eux les ukrainiens vous avez
entendu jean françois colosimo il ya
quelques jours je vous le faire écouter
tiens le président ukrainien volodimir
zelensky qui s'adressait aux occidentaux
à tighennif ça fait treize jours qu'on
entend des promesses treize jours qu'on
nous dit qu'on nous aidera dans le ciel
il y aura des avions ont délivrera
navire balades à dos de la promesse non
tenue des occidentaux oui parce que
effectivement il faut quand même aussi
et ça empêche pas du tout la solidarité
avec le peuple ukrainien mais je pense
que le président de la république l'a
redit ou parfois à expliquer à certains
de ces ministres qui fait avec pas avoir
un langage tout à fait hors sol
c'est-à-dire ne sommes pas en guerre
avec la russie ne voulons pas la
destruction la russie nous avons pas la
rue de la russie et faire ce que demande
le président leur formation de l'ukraine
et la préservation du peuple ukrainien
une no fly zone alors ça les avions se
seraient entre en guerre ça peut sembler
voilà un peu je dirais aux à dire ah ben
c'est très limité ce que vous dites et
puis c'est peut-être a émis du cynisme
c'est malheureusement la réalité aussi
on a entendu les clermontaises de
blagnac poutine sur les scada de
nucléaire n'est ce pas qui dira qu' il
ne le fera pas penser qu'il peut dire
qu'il ne le sait rien c'est la règle en
tout cas on y revenu aux règles de la
guerre froide n'est ce pas et dans les
règles de la guerre froide les choses
sont très claires lorsque vous agissez
d'abord le premier qui arrive dans un
pays s'en empare puisque tout avait lieu
par théâtre interposés à charge pour
l'autre le grand autre dans ce monde
bipolaire ensuite de provoquer une
réaction dans le pays et deuxièmement
wild escalade nucléaire est toujours
possible moi je vois ça aujourd'hui je
pense que vous savez la fameuse horloge
du cadran du monde où on se rapproche de
la possibilité de la destruction les
aiguilles n'ont jamais été aussi avancé
depuis la crise des missiles de cuba
puisque vous êtes avec un homme en face
qui pratique la stratégie du fol haufor
préfet la diagonale du fou dans les
échecs n'est ce pas
et je crois que les paroles américaine
parce que joe biden qui est plutôt
d'ailleurs
antisoviétique voir à peu élevés comme
dans l'anti russie sme lorsqu'ils
expliquent aux polonais que non on ne va
pas livrer des mig qui sont des avions
ce qui serait tout à fait praticable
pour les pilotes ukrainiens et dit non
je crois que malheureusement et c'est
peut-être de là que vient le constat est
la convocation par emmanuel macron des
autres chefs d'état ou de gouvernement
européens
c'est que nous sommes très en retard sur
le calendrier en fait et ça fait 20 ans
30 ans qu'en fait nous tergiversons avec
un problème c'est qu'entre temps le
royaume uni est parti c'était quand même
l'autre puissance militaire parce qu'il
n'est que de réelles française complète
en tout cas la française et la
britannique avec le nucléaire et tout ce
qu'il faut d'armes et autour et puis
deuxièmement il faut le dire c'est que
oui ou non derrière il ya quand même
cette idée juste fini le le poids
s'ouvre à en bonne philosophie politique
c'est lui qui fait la guerre et la paix
c'est pas un parlement qui décide de
faire la pub à 27 28 29 30 alors on va
alors ça veut dire que on peut pas votre
défense s'il n'y a pas de confédération
s'il ya pas de fédération qui veut cette
fédération en europe ou alors on aura un
embryon permanent vous concluez déjà le
débat jean-françois colosimo il n'y aura
jamais de défense européenne où va
essayer d'en discuter au sein ou l'autre
oui confédération fédération marie cas
par cas on va parler de l'allemagne qui
opère un tournant majeur mais vous voyez
comment au fond ce qui est en train de
se jouer ça y'est l'otan se réveille on
la disait en mort cérébrale ça y est les
27 ont enfin eu ni même pour accueillir
on en parlait tout à l'heure des des
réfugiés chacun pour ne sera pas ou au
contraire c'est quand même l'impuissance
qui marque ce soir parce que ça n'arrête
pas poutine
oui c'est sûr que finalement on n'a pas
réussi à dissuader poutine mais
aujourd'hui ce que dit olaf scholz quand
il prend la parole devant le bundestag
le 27 février dernier il dit justement
le monde d'aujourd'hui c'est plus le
monde hier le monde a changé
que vous avez indiquée c'est une
polarisation du monde des relations
internationales le droit international a
été violée ce droit international qui
étaient là pour ne pas recourir à la
violence précisément et pour en fait
être basée sur les traiter les
conventions la diplomatie cette période
là elle est révolue donc on entrevoit en
fait d'ailleurs leur union allemande
aussi qui a énormément pesé la société
civile pour opérer certainement un
changement oui ça on arrive quoi les 100
milliards c'est sa 2e pour moderniser
l'armée allemande effectivement 100
milliards d'euros pour la rendre plus
performante et les mollets en quelle
disposition si vous voulez il ya la
récupération d'un point de vue des
interventions est ce que là aussi les
choses oui de flash naturel très
rapidement ya un reproche qui avait été
fait à l'allemagne c'est à dire de
rester assez atone finalement sur la
livraison des armes à moment donné à
l'ukraine demandé des armes et on avait
livré 5000 casques donc ce qui était
absolument pas du tout à la hauteur de
ce conflit et du danger qu'on courait
les ukrainiens donc aujourd'hui
l'allemagne a vraiment brisé ce tabou il
ya une livraison de ces équipements au
domicile de lance-roquettes d'armes
antichars donc c'est vraiment un
tournant et aujourd'hui l'alba au
pacifisme d'après guerre c'est à dire
que vous avez à un pib enfin 2% du pib
qui vont être consacrés maintenant à la
politique de la défense et finalement
c'est ce que quatre présidents
américains consécutifs avaient demandé à
leurs partenaires que c'est une exigence
de l'otan pour être membre de l'otan il
faut deux pour cent nous on y est arrivé
à peine là avec ce budget il reste des
insuffisances on va on va essayer de
voir ce qu'on peut construire mais les
grandes insuffisances aujourd'hui
militaire en europe les décrire d'abord
ce sont les budgets et effectivement le
virage allemand est une bonne nouvelle
il faut pas se faire d'illusions si la
défense européenne n'a pas existé
jusqu'aujourd'hui s'était longtemps à
cause des britanniques qu'ils ne
voulaient pas en entendre parler et à
cause des allemands qui pensaient que le
monde était redevenu paisible et que
c'était pas la peine
aujourd'hui
avec ce changement allemand nous avons
besoin de plus de dépenses de défense et
je vois la finlande la suède augmenté
leurs dépenses de défense l'autriche
dans des pays qui ne sont pas membres de
l'otan et qui disent c'est vrai il faut
y aller donc ça c'est déjà un premier
changement le deuxième changement c'est
la capacité à avoir une
forme d'état major de l'union européenne
qui puisse commander des opérations en
commun et c'est là où je suis là on
bascule vraiment et lahoud de là on est
dans la loi que le sivos
l'otan aussi est une alliance de pays
souverains et l'otan mènent des
opérations extérieures elle décide par
consensus et il est bien arrivé dans son
histoire avec des succès divers
mais elle y est arrivée l'union
européenne a besoin d'avoir cette
capacité de se décider elle même qu'il
s'agisse soit d'un nouveau président
américain complètement isolationniste
qui nous dirait vos problèmes ne sont
pas les miens c'est tout à fait possible
soit d'un allié turc dont ces c'est
quand même un allié assez particulier et
qui pourraient ne pas planter agence
pour vous a donc la force commune
militaire un amendement a pas européen
le but c'est pas d'un seul concrètement
c'est une armée européenne avec
parce que ça compte le jour un chef
d'état qui va décider s'il fait risquer
leur vie à des soldats toujours comme
dans l'otan comme à l'onu toujours les
états restent souverains sur l'année ses
yeux oui bien sûr à tegick et ensuite
une capacité à s'entraîner ensemble à
avoir des matériels qui fonctionnent
ensemble à faire des exercices des
manoeuvres et à se déployer ensemble
nous avons des toutes petites missions
de l'union européenne mais nous avons
été extrêmement timide la plupart des
mandats sont des mandats de formation
sont des mandats sur la pointe des pieds
c'est mieux que rien mais il faut être
capable de faire plus aujourd'hui ronan
le gleut les républicains sont divisés
sur cette question inverse étage
gaullistes on le connaît comment vous
vous situez vous allez jusqu'à voilà
vouloir une force à commandement comment
pas d'armée européenne au singulier il
ne veut pas y avoir une seule armée
européenne pour déjà une raison toute
simple c'est que le brésil le bric site
a fait une démonstration il est possible
dans l'histoire d'un pays de vouloir
sortir de l'union européenne dès lors un
pays qui aurait confié sa défense à une
armée hausse gulli et une armée
européenne
en quittant l'union européenne se
retrouveraient sans armes et donc donc
27 armés
il existe des lacunes capacitaire en
europe tout à fait considérable
notamment sur le transport de troupes
pour le renseignement et il faut
effectivement qui est une montée en
puissance de la part des nations qui
font partie de l'union européenne en
terme de défense et l'hyper puissance
économique en europe aujourd'hui c'est
l'allemagne qui je le rappelle à plus
d'un milliard de pipe de plus que nous
il ya un milliard de pipe donc à ce que
mille milliards d'écart ou ont fait en
p1 quoi on fait un char comme un avion
comme enjeu c'est le matériel exactement
le scav le système de combat aérien du
futur avec les allemands les espagnols
le mgc sc le char franco allemand comme
miami milliards d'écart de pub entre
l'allemagne et la france quand
l'allemagne passe à plus de 2 % de
fibres pour sa défense ça crée un budget
militaire annuelle de plus de 70
milliards d'euros par an en réalité ce
temps que l'allemagne ne décide pas de
faire un véritable de 2,2 d'investir
pour combler les lacunes capacitaire
c'est encore une fois de plus c'est une
question de volonté politique allemande
c'est parti dans dans les mains de
l'allemagne que va se décider les
contours d'une éventuelle future force
où vous avez qui est la boussole mandat
qui est aussi en plein de construction
qui va être présenté là au mois de mars
donc que c'est aussi tout l'enjeu en
fait elle est d'accord déjà sur les
menaces que ça veut dire la boussole
seule stratégie qu la semaine un camp au
sein de l'union européenne sur les
menaces qui pèsent sur l'union
européenne sur les câbles adopterait les
ressources qu'on va employer les moyens
les partenariats
convoité premier livre blanc de la
défense et ça ça c'est voté par les
vingt-sept à pourrait être décidé le 25
mars au prochain conseil européen
autant vous dire que la guerre d'ukraine
a obligé le projet à être à peu près
complètement réécrit aujourd'hui il est
prêt au sommet de versailles les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement il jette un
premier coup d'oeil y aura les derniers
ajustements il devrait être adopté à la
fin du mois de mars vous croyez en
france
foncez vite en puissance j'admire votre
question oui c'est une question de
croyance semble-t-il parce qu'en fait ça
fait quand même
je pense un peu
vraiment à nos soldats qui sont morts au
mali sans que cette europe qui paraît
aujourd'hui si solidaire ne montre
aucune solidarité ou presque dix nations
dix nations dans l'effort suspect non
mais
je vous ai pas interrompu l'otan l'otan
est sous domination américaine une
coalition ce nouveau que s'il ya un
élément parfaitement dominant n'est ce
pas sinon c'est la débandade pour de la
vérité ou l'inefficacité
un troisièmement quid de notre force
nucléaire elle n'est pas partageable en
théorie n'est ce pas etc etc donc je
trouve que là effectivement l'europe se
trouve prise à la gorge alors d'abord il
ya quelque chose qui est assez faut que
c'est pas le premier conflit qu'on vit
en europe depuis la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale et le conflit en ex
yougoslavie
il ya eu un bon rendement l'otan et
c'était à peu près d un conflit
constitué de façon assez analogue n'est
ce pas bon
ce conflit est arrivé il a provoqué un
sursaut à ce moment là et puis ce
sursaut est retombé parce que c'est le
même scénario qui attend j'en sais rien
je veux pas moi je ne lis pas dans les
boules de cristal ce que je sais c'est
que aujourd'hui effectivement l'europe
qui était tellement fondée sur la paix
qu'on ne savais même plus où elle
s'arrêter où étaient ses frontières
parce qu'elle portait un projet d'utopie
revient dans la réalité par la porte la
plus tragique c'est la porte de la
guerre s'impose à elle d'un coup un
agenda qu'elle avait refusé pendant 20
ans mais est ce que la peur n'est pas au
fond le principal moteur des européens
aujourd'hui est ce que la peur ne peut
pas être un véritable accélérateur et
c'est toujours jean ce
regard de françois hollande hier sur
furent une antenne sur une matinale qui
disait au fond ça n'est pas une question
de volonté c'est une nécessité parce
qu'on a la trouille aujourd'hui donc
c'est une nécessité parce qu'on croit
ans qu'on est moi je n'aime pas du tout
dire voilà on est obligé on croit à ce
qu'on est et on croit à
la valeur du modèle européen et des
ukrainiens selon qu'ils sont en train de
mourir pour ça parce qu'ils rêvent ils
ont été attaqués pour ça ce qui réveille
comme nous
la peur au soutien bon gt gt à marioupol
ya exactement quatre semaines et j'ai re
accueilli ce matin une députée qui elle
venait de karkhiv
qui n'a plus de circonscription et
l'endroit où nous étions à marioupol
n'existe plus ces gens ont changé de
mentalité parce qu'ils n'ont pas connu
l'union soviétique c'est une classe
politique jeunes complètement journée
tourne enfin vers l'europe
il faut pas faire les choses parce qu'on
a peur il faut les jours faire les
choses parce qu'on en a envie
aujourd'hui on a besoin de cette europe
de la défense vous savez il ya deux ans
qui aurait parié qu'ils auraient une
europe de la santé qui aurait parié on
aurait dit la même chose on aurait dit
mais le nos modèles de santé sont
totalement nationaux ils sont même
parfois ceux des länder en allemagne et
chacun fait exactement alors ça va
prendre du temps vous le reconnaissez il
ya une impulsion on a compris la
boussole stratégique réécrite à la
faveur de cette cette guerre qui sont à
quoi on peut s'attendre que je voulais
qu'ensuite on parle de la question des
réfugiés qui est un autre défi on va
voir comment il va s'installer dans la
durée pour les européens comment vous
voyez la suite
dans l'est dans les arcanes des
décisions européennes on va on va on va
quoi on va on va arriver à déboucher sur
des décisions à quel horizon avec quelle
efficacité concrètes en matière de
défense est là ont corrigé renforcement
des budgets
capacité à pour tout de suite c'est pour
tout de suite il ya des choses qui ont
été pensés trop petit ça c'est ça c'est
l'éternel défaut des européens qui
pensent que en tirant un petit peu sur
les budgets on va y arriver au moment de
la négociation du précédent budget
européen je me suis beaucoup énervé en
disant écoutez vous pensez vraiment que
on peut consacrer au transport de
troupes et au transport de matériel
aussi peu que ce que vous prévoyez un
milliard ça ne suffira pas évidemment
maintenant tout le monde se lamente en
dix ans pour beaucoup plus on a commencé
à mettre 8 milliards d'euros pour de la
recherche du développement de nouveaux
armements ensemble entre européens on
sait qu'il fallait d'autres il ya de
quoi mettre le paquet d'avants amy sia
sentiment d'urgence et la france et
pourquoi l'idée d'un emprunt tous
ensemble à la pour être capable comme
une industrie en de relance on a des
instruments on a le front européen de la
défense on a escola coopération
structurée permanente donc on a des
instruments même si évidemment ils ont
souvent volés
quand on parlait autonomie stratégique
et souveraineté européenne ont passé par
pour des pour des allumés les français
aujourd'hui je n'entends que ça que ça
autour de moi au conseil au parlement
européen à la commission tout le monde
réfléchit et la question de l'énergie du
gaz est évidemment aussi central tout le
monde réfléchit je voudrais noter sur la
fin des dépendance vis-à-vis de régime
qui nous sont hostiles on voit que les
choses sont enclenchées la question
c'est le calendrier maintenant très
concrètement j'aimerais qu'on termine ce
débat avec un autre sujet mais qui est
évidemment européen celui des réfugiés
ils sont deux millions deux millions
d'ukrainiens avoir choisi l'exil clément
perreault se trouve à la frontière
polonaise avec l'ukraine il a pu se
rendre dans un immense camp de réfugiés
il nous décrit ce soir ce que vivent ces
familles qui ont réussi à fuir
depuis le début de la guerre déjà plus
d'un million deux cent mille réfugiés
ukrainiens sont arrivés ici en pologne
pour la plupart il s'agit de femmes
d'enfants et de personnes âgées les
hommes en âge de combattre sont eux dans
leur majorité à rester en ukraine alors
la pologne fait face tant bien que mal à
cet afflux à cet afflux de un réfugié
aujourd'hui nous étions en gare de
varsovie comme vous pouvez le voir sur
ces images la gare est très engorgée par
une arrivée très importante de réfugiés
mais déjà l'accueil commence à
s'organiser on voit des espaces de
couchage pour les familles qui doivent y
rester parfois plusieurs nuits également
un espace pour que les enfants puissent
jouer une aide humaine terre arrivent de
différents pays nous avons croisé des
bénévoles par exemple français allemand
italien qui distribue des vêtements
la nourriture ce que nous disent ces
bénévoles c'est que nous ne sommes
qu'aux débuts de sets un flux
migratoires et que dans les prochains
jours les prochaines semaines et bien la
pologne s'attend vraiment à une vague
massive de réfugiés l'important nous
distiller bien vous c'est qu'il y ait
une vraie coordination européenne pour
que les réfugiés soient vite pris en
charge et envoyés vers les différents
pays européens en mesure de les
accueillir et si nous sommes à lublin à
quelques kilomètres de la frontière
ukrainienne c'est un peu la même chose à
la frontière avec des ukrainiens et qui
arrivent en nombre et des équipes
humanitaires qui attendent encore une
meilleure coordination pour que les
choses se fassent plus rapidement la
pologne c'est vraiment le pays
stratégique 1 pour l'accueil des
réfugiés 1 c'est la porte d'entrée pour
ceux qui veulent être pris en charge
dans les différents pays européens pas
là clément perreault est la frontière
pollet pologne ukraine quel contraste la
pologne quand on se souvient de la crise
avec les migrants syrien et la
biélorussie qu'elle contraste et semur
quel est ce qu'on peut et est-ce qu'on
peut s'imaginer au ronan le gleut cette
fois que l'europe de manière solidaire
et assumée va réussir à prendre en
charge tous tous les réfugiés ukrainien
qui viendront sonner à notre porte je
pense que oui et d'ailleurs les images
qu'on vient de voir on aurait pu tourner
des images tout à fait similaire à la
gare centrale de berlin où actuellement
arrive des réfugiés depuis la pologne
justement je rappelle que berlin est à
900 km de lviv et des citoyens des
berlinois se rendent à la gare de berlin
et lèvent la main quand on leur propose
d'accueillir chez eux en général ce sont
plutôt des femmes parce que les hommes
entre 18 et 60 ans sont évidemment
engagés dans le conflit et parfois avec
des enfants et d'être accueillis par les
familles par les faits par les berlinois
eux mêmes et les capacités d'accueil de
la ville de bin d'ailleurs arrive
rapidement à saturation donc on va se
déporte vers lourds l'allemand gaulle
donne l'exemple et ensuite ça continue
on verra suivent leur chemin on verra si
on peut garder cet optimisme et 7,7
confiance parce que cette guerre va
durer malheureusement et
et les ukrainiens vont voir affluer en
masse on va s'arrêter là j'aurais bien
aimé savoir si vous vous souhaitez que
l'ukraine peut être entre dans l'union
je vous pose la question très rapidement
peut-être que ces sujets va se poser ce
soir est-ce que c'est souhaitable pas
forcément dans dix ans est-ce que c'est
souhaitable de leur dire venez d'abord
il faut leur donner un espoir
aujourd'hui parce qu'ils sont en train
de se battre et de souffrir énormément
et aussi entre temps puisque ces
processus sont très longs il faut faire
quelque chose pour les rapprocher encore
tout de suite
après l'union européenne elle-même a
beaucoup besoin de changer il faut
qu'elle soit capable le cas échéant
d'être à plusieurs vitesses d'être un
peu différente mais en tout cas les pays
qui regarde vers nous n'ayons pas
l'impudence de leur dire qu'ils ne nous
intéresse pas merci on va s'arrêter là
merci beaucoup d'être venu sur le
plateau des cp on va continuer à essayer
de comprendre cette guerre en ukraine
avec vous jean françois colosimo vous
rester avec moi comment vladimir poutine
a pu au fond penser qu'une nation
l'ukraine ont une partie entre en tout
cas des des ukrainiens pouvait
l'accueillir avec ses chars à bras
ouverts comment at il pu faire preuve
d'un tel aveuglement vous allez voir on
obtient plein plein de questions à vous
poser regarder ce sujet il est signé
elsa mon égard
si on vous invite jean françois
colossimo c'est pour vous proposer un
défi vertigineux vous mettre dans la
tête de vladimir poutine
en envahissant l'ukraine le maître du
kremlin a déclenché une guerre aux
portes de l'europe et s'est invitée dans
la campagne présidentielle français à
vladimir poutine monsieur poutine
vladimir poutine le président poutine je
serai président durant ses jours et ses
semaines autant que je le dois mais je
serai candidat à chaque fois que je le
peux je crois qu'aujourd'hui la guerre
en ukraine et creston elle écrase cette
campagne ne vous laissez pas voler cette
élection
[Applaudissements]
imposé
imposer le débat à ceux qui le refusent
c'est du sable chaud monsieur poutine
est aussi fou certainement là quand même
pas la possibilité de fixer les
élections en france donc on est obligé
de faire le job jean françois colossimo
vous êtes historians éditeurs mais aussi
théologiens spécialistes du monde
orthodoxe dans vos livres vous vous
intéressez à ces liens entre religion
politique histoire pour vous le
président russe a agi par opportunisme
parce qu'il a pensé que le pouvoir de
baden était faible à washington que
l'allemagne avait une nouvelle équipe
dirigeante que la france était en
campagne électorale que boris johnson
avait beaucoup de problèmes à londres et
que c'était le moment ou jamais nous
comptons sur vous pour comprendre ce qui
motive l'ancien agent du kgb pourquoi at
il voulu cette guerre pardon cette
opération militaire spéciale expression
consacrée par la propagande russe
vladimir poutine un dictateur froid
ayant pour objectif de recréer l'empiré
russe où un dirigeant versant dans la
paranoïa voir la folie
quelles que soient ses motivations pour
vous poutine à d'ores et déjà échoué
unités de l'union européenne
renforcement de l'otan résistance du
peuple ukrainien rien ne s'est passé
comme prévu et pourtant en ukraine les
combats continuent alors d'après vous
qui peut arrêter vladimir poutine est-il
encore entièrement soutenu au kremlin
peut-il être désavoué par sa population
par l'église quelques questions pour
tenter de résoudre
l'énigme poutine
voilà l'ambition et est de taille jean
françois colosimo on commence par cette
question
l'aveuglément le déni de vladimir
poutine comment vous expliquer cette
erreur majeure d'avoir cru que ce peuple
ukrainien aller l'accueillir au nom
d'une histoire d'une langue d'une
culture et pour partie d'une d'une
religion orthodoxe connaît oui pas
besoin de partir puisque 70% des
ukrainiens sont orthodoxes même si
beaucoup d'entre eux rêver
d'indépendance passablement politique
mais aussi ecclésiastiques depuis très
longtemps la vérité c'est que vladimir
poutine
a je dirais à ce trouble cognitif ça
c'est sûr on va pas le psychiatrisés on
va pas le rendre plus fous qu'il n'est
mais pour lui c'est une évidence que la
l'ukraine et la biélorussie le bélarus
n'ont pas de destin séparer possible de
la russie donc vladimir poutine n'est
pas dans un calcul d'essayer par exemple
de convaincre les ukrainiens ou les
biélorusses qu'ils seraient des russes
comme ceux qui habitent en fédération de
russie
il répare en fait une erreur de
l'histoire il est persuadé de son bien
fondé puisque l'autre hypothèse n'existe
pas et je répondrai n'existe pas parce
que ce sont pas les peuples qui décide
c'est l'histoire qui décide pour les
peuples sauf que les peuples ont voté en
l'occurrence le peuple ukrainien et
cette partie à l'est cette partie
russophone orthodoxe a décidé elle aussi
leur dépendance et ça il ne l'a jamais
voulu ça il n'a jamais compris n'ai
jamais cru non c'était pas une
possibilité qui voyaient leur écoute et
qu'on jeu tout ça je suis pas en train
d'exprimer mes idées mais on essaie de
se mettre
d essayer de la comprendre my est où la
logique parce qu'il faut pas voir cette
aventure terrible qui marie ukraine
comme totalement illogique n'est ce pas
au sens où le fou c'est celui qui a tout
perdu sauf la raison donc lui procède
selon des instances qu'est-ce qu'il n'a
pas vu venir il n'a pas vu venir de
toute façon que à elle et huit ans de
guerre larvée parfois ouvertes entre les
milices séparatistes les milices
unionistes et l'armée régulière une
chrétienne qui se déroulait au donbass
dans l'est n'est ce pas que ces huit
années ont véritablement
épuisé d'abord le sentiment de
solidarité avec la russie
parce que les chefs des milices et brad
east sont en fait des chefs mafieux et
qui ont véritablement
esclavagisés ce pays et cette population
donc une forme de désillusion sur le
grand frère russe et puis deuxièmement
non ce qui n'a pas compris c'est qu'il y
à ce réflexe atavique le partisan
telluriques ont 10 à spa en philosophie
pauline défense à terre c'est à dire que
vous voyez de degas arriver dans une
jeep ils parlent la même langue que vous
ils vous disent qu'ils ont leurs raisons
que nous et ils vous disent qu'ils sont
venus nous libérer et vous disent très
bien attendez une seconde vous rentrez
dans votre branche vous prenez note
refusent-ils et vous leur tirez dessus
parce qu'ils n'ont rien à faire là parce
qu'ils sont étrangers et donc si vous
voulez vous avez d'un côté ce sentiment
que le russe n'est pas chez lui en
ukraine qui est partagé par tous les
ukrainiens quels qu'ils soient et
techniquement linguistiquement
confessionnellement ça change pas grand
chose à ça et de l'autre le fait que
poutine était persuadé qu'il était chez
lui et ça explique le choc profond et le
dévissage de l'armée russe au départ
alors petit ne se rêve un peu historien
il adore réécrire
revisiter l'histoire il ya une forme de
système d'amnésie ils manipulent
l'histoire expliqué nous ça on l'a bien
vu d'ailleurs dans son discours pour
justifier l'entrée en guerre d'amnésie
sais-tu malheureusement une combi sion
aujourd'hui de la virus puisque comment
voulez vous que cette russie qui
passablement elles s'étaient toutes
l'union soviétique c'était par de
l'union soviétique tous les pays de
l'est qui a vécu le totalitarisme
eh bien on l'empêchent de penser le
totalitarisme est en quelque sorte de le
purger puisque la mémoire du
totalitarisme est interdite
sa peinture est interdite parce qu'on ne
saurait critiqué le communisme sinon il
n'y a plus de continuité or comment
réécrite et l'histoire elie lempire
saristes l'union soviétique
particulièrement stalinienne et moi il
n'y a qu'une seule et même russie qui
n'a cessé de se métamorphoser
les teens commun nicolas de staline
absolument tine que portent certains
russes que portent beaucoup de russes
qui sont ces soutiens en solitaire
oui nicolas de staline poutine il n'y a
pas eu de contradictions dans le destin
russe il n'y a pas eu d'expérience du
goulag et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
alors que dans ce goulag très
précisément ci est malheureusement une
fraternité profonde de tous ces peuples
les baltes les ukrainiens les
biélorusses les russes mais aussi des
tchétchènes mais aussi les juifs les
arméniens c'est dans la souffrance du
totalitarisme différentes et au goulag
or que fait-il vania poutine eh bien
il interdit mémorial l'association créée
par andré sakharov le grand physicien un
gars n'étaient dissidents qui étaient là
pour archiver la mémoire du goulag la
recueillir déjà très empêcher cette
association qui à compter des morts
parmi ses membres et ses rangs il l'a
interdite il a il vient de braquer le
travail de mémorial sur 30 ans avec ses
avec sa garde prétorienne ya une
perquisition terrible c'était jeudi
dernier
et il faut dire à notre honneur c'est
pas un discours partisan que j'ai l'âge
laissons les élections la campagne de
côté que tcherkassof alexandre
tcherkassov qui est aujourd'hui le
patron mémorial le suisse est sakharov
et elle a entouré des policiers voyant
le spectacle désolant des archives n'est
ce pas de l'horreur du drame total
militaires embarqués par les jambes
poutine son téléphone a sonné et au bout
du fil il y avait et emmanuel macron qui
lui disait que la france est avec lui
nous avons des raisons aussi de temps en
temps malgré tout de bien voir grâce à
cette politique là que l'enjeu est
d'abord culturel
nous dire parfois vous dans vos
interviews vous vous mentionnez cette
rumeur qui circule à moscou d'une
maladie neuro dégénérative
on a l'impression de toute façon qui est
une forme de saut dans le vide que c'est
une forme de fuite en avant et qu'il a
en partie déjà perdu parce que rien ne
s'est passé comme prévu c'est possible
vous croyez être humain alors
l'accélération à laquelle on assiste
elle est claire elle participe d'une
angoisse de la mort parce que en fait ce
qu'il veut c'est véritablement cimenté
bétonner son héritage est obligé son
successeur en quelque sorte il ne fait
pas confiance à son potentiel successeur
c'est lui l'incarnation depuis 22 ans du
haut du redressement de ce malheur le
malheur est essentielle pour l'avenir
poutine c'est pas le goulag ou intimes
siècle c'est pas le choix c'est la chute
de l'urss donc obligé son successeur
maintenant il a plus le temps ça fait 22
ans qu'il est là alors est-ce qu'il est
malade en plus peut-être est-ce qu'il
faut parier là-dessus certainement pas
est-ce qu'il faut parier sur le fait
qu'il y à des oligarques que fâchés de
ne plus pouvoir aller visiter leurs
coffres en suisse qui peut l'arrêter
très maniéré rocky ben là c'est de voir
ce massacre
aujourd'hui difficile à dire évidemment
dont il faut pas parié là dessus je
pense que malade ou pas il va de toute
façon laissé l'ukraine en ruine malade
ou pas et il va de toute façon résister
aux oligarques et aux généraux parce
qu'il a les moyens c'est un cagibi il a
prévu tout ça sert pas y'a des goûteurs
pour ses repas etc nous n'avons pas
facile de le reposer un coup d'état la
garde rapprochée tout ça n'est pas
imaginable c'est pas disons que
parier sur cette hypothèse là c'est un
peu du wishful thinking comme on dit en
enlever ses implants la pensée magique
pour terminer parce que notre nez car
nous attendent qu'est ce qui peut se
passer on va replonger dans une guerre
froide pour le russe et les ports russes
sont muselés il a t-il à il a pendant un
an avant l'opération de l'ue fred il a
décapité tout ce qu'il y avait de maya
et d'opposants étaient invités à revivre
les russes furent massa le pays et il
n'y a pas que jésus christ ans ils
fuient leur pays les russes aussi donc
il est en train de créer ce vide là il
nous faut en fait nous armer d'un
véritable contre projet ce contre projet
il ne concerne pas simplement les
ukrainiens et les russes bien que ce
soit notre premier souci il concerne
aussi le retour des empires dans le
monde et notre faiblesse désormais face
à cette bascule géopolitique du monde il
faut que nous reprenions non seulement
que l'histoire est tragique mais qu'il
faut savoir s'opposer à la cruauté un
appel au sursaut donc merci beaucoup
vous restez avec nous jean françois
colosimo parce qu'on va ouvrir à présent
une part présidentielle ces cellules de
blacko tout de suite un j -30 et avant
le premier tour chaque soir stéphane
blakowski et son carnet de campagne la
clause 8
[Musique]
bonsoir stéphane bon sens myriam bonsoir
monsieur connu des fans blakowski qu'est
ce qui a attiré votre oeil aujourd'hui
alors autant vous dire que ce matin je
n'avais pas les yeux en face des trous
je vous rappelle que nous sommes au
lendemain de l'élimination du psg en
ligue des champions donc j'avais un peu
du vague à l'âme je suis dit mieux vaut
faire confiance au cerveau froide ou
l'algorithme donc j'ai tapé
présidentielle sur google et voilà quel
est l'événement aujourd'hui la
présidentielle et bien c'est le fait que
emmanuel macron propose de
déclamer les retraites voilà l'âge de la
retraite jusqu'à 65 ans vous savez que
donc le candidat macron ne fait pas
vraiment en panne puisque le président
macron est occupée par la guerre en
ukraine donc c'est gabriel attal qui
s'est chargé halimi danser ça sur rtl
vous allez voir qu'à travers cette
annonce on voit à peu près les piliers
de la campagne macron c'est à dire
premièrement on s'aligne sur ce que font
les autres européens deuxièmement au
n'augmentera pas les impôts et donc
troisièmement si on n'augmente pas les
impôts il faut travailler plus on écoute
c'est un choix de société et qu'on voit
autour de nous en allemagne en espagne
en italie au royaume uni on part déjà à
65 ans et donc il s'agit aussi de
s'aligner sur quand même la plupart des
de nos voisins et des pays comparables
encore une fois parce qu'on ne veut pas
augmenter les impôts des français et que
donc si on veut financer leur protection
et l'investissement dans l'avenir il
faut travailler plus voilà donc réformer
les retraites en 2022 me l'avez pas déjà
promis en 2010 est bon dieu myriam mais
ce que vous pouvez être cruel parfois
mais peut-être que c'est la réalité
d'ailleurs qu'est cruel parce que
effectivement en 2010 être macron avait
promis de réformer les retraites et il
ne l'a pas fait donc voyez valérie
pécresse avait enfin une occasion de
marquer des points elle ne l'a pas ratée
immédiatement twitté puisque l os qui
propose la même mesure que macron la
retraite à 65 ans elle a dit puisque le
président main qu'on ne l'a pas fait
pour quoi faire confiance aux candidats
macron donc en fait il est un peu plombé
par son bilan sur la question des
retraites madame pourquoi il n'avait pas
pu le faire ce système des retraites par
points alors l'amiable j'aimerais bien
vous expliquer malheureusement je n'ai
c'est mon boulot normalement mais je
n'ai jamais rien compris au système de
la retraite par points j'en ai même
conçu une certaine déception je me
disais c'est quand même la preuve de
maître de mes limites intellectuelles et
puis alors soulagement ce matin j'écoute
france info qu'est ce que j'apprends
figurez vous que
richard ferrand qui est donc le
président de l'assemblée le pilier de la
macro ni l'ami intime de maquereaux lui
non plus il n'a jamais rien compris à ce
système de radar écoute nous avions
essayé de faire un système de retraite
qui était plus juste mais dont beaucoup
se sont accordés estimé qu'il était trop
compliqué peu lisible j'ai même entendu
usine à gaz system universités s'étaient
pas faux parce que cela crée un trouble
général et personne de ne voyait clair
et si même richard ferrand n'y a rien
compris donc forcément il y avait un
problème voilà vous êtes toujours
excuser qu'est ce que les autres
candidats proposent sur les retraites
bat vous savez en fait à part zemmour
pécresse et macro n'y a aucun autre
candidat qui a envie d'allonger l'âge de
la retraite alors que les trois quarts
des candidats sont opposés à cette idée
de retraite à 65 ans et en fait ça n'a
rien de très étonnant puisque c'est
aussi qu'à des français on parle
toujours de sondages bien sondage sur
les retraites 80% des français n'ont pas
envie de bosser jusqu'à 65 ans alors
bien qui paradoxe dire que quand on leur
parle immigration et insécurité les
français sont de droite en revanche
quand on leur parle retraite là ils sont
carrément de gauche et c'est un peu ce
que disait il ya yannick jadot ce matin
je trouve que cette mesure qui cookies
qui est porteur de fuite en avant de la
droite à laquelle appartient pris
clairement emmanuel macron ses tubes ray
une vraie mesure d'injustice sociale et
de mépris pour les personnes qui
travaillent durement dans ce pays mais
on termine avec jean luc mélenchon vous
n'avez pas parlé et marine le pen ou
avec la tène le pen et mélenchon bien
sûr l'on va faire vite c'est la fin de
la chronique donc pour mélenchon le
tweet voilà vous savez qu'il se voit
maintenant déjà au 2e tour donc il
s'attend à ce qu'on ait à choisir au
second tour entre lui qui propose la
retraite à 60 ans ou macron la retraite
à 65 ans bon en réalité celle qui a
priori qualifiée selon les sondages au
second tour c'est marine le pen qui fait
une de près les mêmes propositions un
peu plus nuancé on attend pas à nuancer
pour marine le pen mais elle dit aussi
retraite à 60 ans pour ceux qui ont 40
annuités la conclusion c'est que si
l'élection présidentielle devait se
jouer sur la question des retraites eh
bien ce n'est pas si sûr que macro soit
pas sûr que ce soit l'unique sujet merci
beaucoup merci stéphane mahé à demain
l'oeil de blacko vous le savez c'est
votre rendez vous désormais sur la
campagne présidentielle tous les soirs
on continue à parler justement de ce
grand rendez vous démocratique avec nos
chroniqueurs c'est le scan tout de suite
mais avant l'e3 il y aller devant
fatalité au grand remplacement
de la môle vous propose le rouge
d'helmand d'agir pour lui que
l'assimilation
la république chez moi la prendre orange
ma chronique
haweij aux travailleurs le système bose
exclu il ya un vrai problème de pouvoir
d'achat rendre à la france sa grandeur
car ça c'est la fin de l'histoire c'est
le bol
le scan voilà comme tous les soirs sur
cette campagne présidentielle il reste
confus vous imaginez à peine 31 jours
personne à réaliser que c'est dans 30
jours à peine qu'on va faire un choix au
moins pour le premier tour bonsoir
thomas legrand france inter m avec
nourrichard wehrli bonbons soit vous
rentrez à peine de versailles vous allez
nous raconter tout ça et emmanuel du
crew de l'opinion bonsoir on commence à
aller très vite avec vous riche à
emmanuel macron s'est posée franchement
en héraut d'une europe unie on peut le
dire comme ça pour aider l'ukraine pas
de doute pour vous macron le pro
européen va tirer profit pour lui c'est
tout bénéfice comme on dit cette grande
entreprise à versailles alors c'est
évident et d'ailleurs ils haussent tout
la preuve il recommence avec le drapeau
européen sous l'arc de triomphe
immédiatement ses adversaires l'ont
pilonné vous savez cette polémique
drapeau français qui a disparu pendant
une journée au profit du rapport aux
pairs et bien et même à cran il a
recommencé aujourd'hui pour l'accueil à
versailles des 26 autres chefs d'état et
de gouvernement de l'union européenne
c'est dire qu'il est sûr de son coup
parce que ce sommet là alors c'est un
sommet informel il faut le dire donc ce
n'est pas un sommet qui est supposé
prendre des décisions mais de toute
manière le scénario d'un nom d'un veto
il est juste impensable parce que les
différents sujets qui sont sur la table
que ce soit d'une part les sanctions à
l'exception du gaz évidemment les
sanctions ou bien la question de la
défense européenne aujourd'hui tout le
monde est pour on n'est plus du tout
dans le scénario de juillet 2020 vous
savez le fameux sommet sur le plan de
relance européen où il y avait d'un côté
les pays frugaux les pays bas les pays
nordiques et d'autres comme la france
qui plaidait pour cet emprunt comme
commun qui finalement a eu lieu alors
merci vladimir poutine d'une certaine
manière merci surtout aussi volodymyr
zelensky parce que la figure du
président ukrainien elle est extrêmement
fédératrice donc en tant que président
tournant l'union européenne emmanuel
macron aujourd'hui il a un boulevard ça
on s'en était un peu rendu compte mais
il a surtout un boulevard au tour de la
table des négociations parce que les
anti bruxelles
non pas anti européen et anti bruxelles
comme viktor orban ils ont purement et
simplement perdu leur boussole parce que
eux aussi ils ont besoin d'une europe
puissance qu'ils puissent défendre leurs
intérêts on en a parlé largement dans la
première partie l'europe puissance
l'europe l'europe l'europe richard à
force de parler d'europe ils s'éloignent
pas le candidat macron des français et
bien je ne le crois pas parce que les
français aussi se rendent compte
aujourd'hui qu'ils ont besoin de cette
puissance européenne il va y avoir
besoin de la solidarité solidarité
européenne pour accueillir les réfugiés
le craignent en est là ce que va faire
la commission va être très important il
y avait globalement un besoin de
pragmatisme de deux communautés on
l'avait vu rappelez vous au moment de la
pandémie sur les vaccins et bien là la
sécurité c'est un peu pareil et même
l'approvisionnement énergétique parce
que tout le monde même si on n'est pas
prêt à le faire aujourd'hui réalise
qu'il va falloir se passer du gaz russe
pour se passer du gaz russe il faut de
nouvelles infrastructures électriques il
faut de nouveaux terminaux portuaires et
ça il faut pouvoir le financer à
plusieurs c'est à dire à 27 au fond dans
tous les cas de figure aujourd'hui
l'europe qu'on le veuille ou non elle
est devenue indispensable à cause de ce
qui se passe en ukraine
emmanuel macron et porter forcément et
s'écrier c'est son projet je crois que
il a dégainé enfin il ya une rencontre
sa façon l'histoire
entre une fausse balle en dehors de
l'échéance présidentielle si on observe
il rencontre
l'histoire lui lui offre la capacité une
capacité de démontrer son propre projet
politique d'où ce fameux drapeau
européen exhibé enfin cette son projet
sa souveraineté européenne il a dit je
crois qu'il voulait placer un grand
commentateur politique moi mais vous les
placez la campagne sous ce sigle là bon
maintenant il fera qu'un expliqué un
jour ce que c'est que la souveraineté un
tweet j'ai bien senti que j'étais
sceptique lors du premier alors est ce
que c'est un pouf ballon n'ouvre pas le
débat parce qu'on va garder raison pour
ne rien faire du tout faux
alors je suis sûr que cela vous
intéresserait aussi jean françois
colosimo vous d'y revenir thomas sur la
méthode poutine pour bombarder les
ukrainiens une forme de signature
absolument glaçante qui n'est pas
nouvelle non on est abasourdi par la
violence de la guerre il s'en prend aux
hôpitaux aux supermarchés alors il avait
proposé des couloirs humanitaires
pour évacuer les civils mais des
couloirs qui menait vers la russie c'est
donc une provocation tout à fait cynique
et en fait ça ne devrait pas nous
surprendre parce que nous avions une
répétition générale de tous a d'abord à
grozny en tchétchénie mais surtout en
syrie alep et à homs et aussi dans la
banlieue de damas
dans les années à partir de 2015
vladimir poutine avait avait était
intervenu en russie parce que la france
n'avait pas réussi à compenser les
américains en syrie pardon n'avait pas
réussi à convaincre les américains en
2013 quand quand bachar el assad a à
bombarder son peuple avec des armes
chimiques dans la banlieue de damas
c'était la ligne rouge et françois
hollande n'a pas réussi à embarquer avec
lui barack obama pour intervenir c'était
ce qui était prévu mais barack obama en
gros s'est dégonflé et donc ce
désengagement a laissé la place libre à
vladimir poutine et en 2015 à partir de
2015 et bien
venir vous critiquez est venu à la
rescousse de bachar el-assad le terrain
était libre et les russes contrairement
à ce qu'ils ont annoncés n'ont pas du
tout d'abord combattu des ch ils ont
combattu les opposant l'armée libre
syrienne et ils ont bombardé ils ont
bombardé des villes ils ont bombardé des
hôpitaux où la prédilection sur les
hôpitaux pour pouvoir créer une sorte de
des interviews et une panne il pas
l'accepter c'était terrible et ça a été
très documentée par des tas de
reportages et par des tas de témoignages
des films aussi des documentaires et on
a l'impression qu'on n'a pas vraiment vu
qu'on n'a pas vraiment on s'est pas
rendu compte de de cette chose terrible
et il ya eu un brouillage qui a été
accompagné par certains en france par
certains on va les voir maintenant
la dmr poutine sait pertinemment qu'il
en va de l'intérêt de son pays
l'intérêt c'est d'abord d'éviter la
compag à sion du fondamentalisme
islamiste en russie en lançant ces
avions dans la bataille en réduisant la
ville d'alep en miettes poutine a sauvé
le régime syrien pris de vitesse et
occidentaux et montrer que le choix
était binaire on ne pourra pas mettre le
régime de bachar el-assad d'or sans
l'accord de la russie puisque la russie
assure la sécurité de ce régime a failli
très mal il ya aussi jean luc mélenchon
qui avait dit que vladimir poutine était
la solution très loin s'en est dit ça
avant les bombardements dans ses
déclarations ne veulent pas dire que
évidemment françois fillon eric zemmour
ou marine le pen approuve les
bombardements mais enfin il ya une sorte
de minimisation et moi je trouve que
c'est assez incroyable et et surtout ça
fait partie d'une sorte de realpolitik
ces déclarations se présenter sous le
signe de la realpolitik août alors que
le désastre humanitaire bon il ya le
désastre humanitaire mais il ya aussi un
désastre stratégique parce que
finalement les russes sont installés
maintenant à l'est de la méditerranée il
contrôle le ciel donc d'un point de vue
de la realpolitik des intérêts de la
france puisque c'est ça la realpolitik
se défend les intérêts de son pays c'est
une catastrophe et puis aussi c'est la
cause bd des vagues migratoires qui
déstabilisent les pays voisins et aussi
un peu l'europe voilà d'une d'un
bombardement à l'autre la signature
comptines rapidement qui mérite
d'interroger pourquoi il n'ya pas plus
d'avions russes dans le ciel ukrainien
en ce moment il ya très peu de
bombardements aériens ça doit sans doute
vouloir dire qu'il ne contrôle pas
réelle à cause des armements qu'on leur
livre qu'on trouve pas le notamment les
contrôles et le sol pas de noms mais de
les voir c'est à celje jean françois
colossimo la chronique des manuels du
coup parce qu une fois n'est pas coutume
il ya ceux qui sont rattrapés par leurs
propos et puis est ce qu'ils s'excusent
moment de sincérité en politique oui
c'est suis qu'un livre et robert ménard
le maire de biens de béziers hier soir
sur le plateau de david pujadas était
sûr et si je vous laisse écouter moi je
vais plaider coupable g
y
écrit
publié à béziers un certain nombre de
choses par exemple au moment de des
combats en syrie est là et en irak et
l'arrivée l'aider des réfugiés chez nous
que je regrette que j'ai honte d'avoir
dit et fait parce que c'était pas bien
parce que moralement c'était pas bien
qui a pas deux sortes de deux victimes
il n'y a pas des européens chrétien
qu'il faudrait défendre et puis les gens
ne sont pas européens qui seraient au
moyen-orient qui serait musulman qu'on
aurait eu raison de ne pas accepter chez
nous je crois que 7,7 cette attitude là
c'est une faute
alors robert ménard à la voix nouée dans
cette danse est extrait il reconnaît non
pas une erreur à la marge il reconnaît
une erreur sur ce qui constitue la
colonne vertébrale de la pensée
d'extrême droite sur les réfugiés
notamment syrien notamment irakien et
quand on dit comme ça ça honte sa honte
on parle vraiment soi c'est un exercice
de confession qui est difficile qui est
quand même assez inattendue la guerre en
ukraine affaire a fait comprendre à
robert ménard ce que l'actualité ne
l'avait pas fait comprendre avant
c'est-à-dire qu'il a traité la détresse
des bombardes et comme s'il y avait deux
poids deux mesures alors on peut
discuter bien sûr c'est bien tard il
aurait fallu y penser avant mais la
prise de conscience est là elle est
publique et ça c'est rare fait très rare
et puis c'est pas si surprenant parce
que il est assez coutumier de volte face
de la sorte robert ménard situons le
c'est un ancien journaliste maire de
béziers élus en 2014 avec le soutien du
front national dont il était proche
partait partageant disait-il 80% des
idées notamment celle sur l'immigration
alors politiquement disons un personnage
éclectique passé par la ligue communiste
révolutionnaire par le ps sympathisants
non encartés du fn professionnellement
aussi un il est passé du siège de
président de reporters sans frontières à
celui du centre pour la liberté de
l'information à doha qatar financé par
l'émir local c'est un peu surprenant et
pourtant robert ménard surprend tout de
même des hommes politiques qui avoue
s'être trompé ça arrive mais
généralement ce n'est pas vraiment leur
faute c'est les circonstances c'est
l'opposition ou ce qu'on peut réseau
résumé par le désormais célèbre ce n'est
pas un échec mais ça n'a pas marché d
macron en pleine crise de qu'ovide bon
l'a fait autre chose oui parce que c'est
un exercice de sincérité d'honnêteté
intellectuelle d'autant plus remarquable
qu'il revient à brûler tous ses
vaisseaux politique des vaisseaux dans
la coque desquels robert ménard a percé
des trous que ces derniers temps
assurant que le chef de l'état avait
raison de vouloir emmerder les
non-vaccinés même c'est un peu choquant
déplorant que son camp politique refuse
de dire que vladimir poutine était un
dictateur alors après cette épiphanie
soudaine quel avenir politique pour
robert ménard rupture et isolement ou à
moins que cela ne se traduise par un
retour en respectabilité ah oui et très
rapidement en livres et en ralliements
autres d'autres attendent et très vite
elle est très vite parce qu'on a plus
beaucoup de temps ça vous rappelle un
autre à franchir politique sans préjuger
de l'avenir robert ménard à l'extrême
droite une sorte de jumeaux de destin de
fabien roussel il s'affranchit des codes
et dans des dans des écosystèmes
politique d'extrême droite ou gauche qui
ressemblent à des pistes de super g vous
savez ces techniques ça va vite où
l'exercice consiste à ne pas rater une
porte idéologique parce que ça savoir
disqualifie et eux ils passent à côté
ils font du hors piste et ça leur
réussit plutôt bien merci beaucoup et
manuela ralliement j'entendais ce mot
est possible voilà j'ai pas bu
rapprochement qu'est ce que vous voyez
derrière les vaisseaux dans ses
mouvements
dans un mot pour finir navalni du fond
de sa prison dit horus descendez dans la
rue je suis rentré d'allemagne et je me
suis laisser emprisonner par poutine
pour être en droit de vous dire
manifester mettez votre vie en danger
parce qu'il est plus que la vie physique
c'est je crois un ce sera vous pensez je
pense pas que ça soit parce qu'elles ont
débouclé déjà cette année la visite en
tout cas grand merci jean françois
colosimo d'être venu sur le plateau de
lcp merci à vous trois à travailler très
belle soirée documentaire à présent et à
demain
[Musique]